james is starting off this hour in tampa
florida hi james welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hey guys how are you great man how can
we help
so questions for you uh for you both
here
um right now i am 24
and i have a great job and i'm not
quite sure where i should be saving my
my money at um i've got been pretty
financially responsible
i would say um as of now but
like to start thinking about saving for
a home but i don't know if florida is my
forever place so just looking for some
guidance from you guys
good for you so how much debt do you
have
uh no debt not at all
nope no student loan no car payment no
sir
okay very good pretty good buddy uh
did you ever have debt at all james
uh i didn't i was very fortunate that my
parents helped me
through college and took care of that
for me so and
definitely seeing the the returns on
that so i
owe them a lot and they really set me up
that's pretty cool dude yes it
is so what do you make a year i make
about
50 000 base and then
submission on top of that and how much
do you have in savings
about 40 000. good for you
all right well dude you're right you're
on top of the world you're way ahead of
the game for
a typical 54 year old much less a 24
year old
so um average 54 year old in america
can't lay their hands on a thousand
dollars cash so you're like
50 x of that or 40 x of that well done
uh so excellent job excellent job well
you probably
if you've been listening for more than
10 minutes we talk about the baby steps
yep
absolutely and that's where you want to
get a thousand dollars which james you
can do that
that's going to help you break the habit
of using debt forward and you've got 40
so you're well beyond
no debt so that's baby step two baby
step three is three to six months of
emergency fund
you're there uh so now buddy you want to
start investing 15
are you investing yet uh
i am i'm doing about five percent
right now i wanted to that's where i
wanted to start i've already made the
plane to
up that come uh beginning of 2021.
good um and i already started talking to
someone about that as well
yeah let's get that up to 15 percent
let's allocate
some of the 40 000 for your emergency
fund of three to six months
of expenses i'll just make up a number
let's say
fifteen thousand dollars is your
emergency fund okay
it's probably somewhere around there you
decide set that in a different account
just a money market account just sitting
there okay if we did that that would
leave 25 000
in the second account correct yep
and that's your down payment money where
you're saving for your house
above the 15 that you're putting into
retirement beginning in 2021 any more
money that you can save and dude you're
a saver
uh you've been watching you're watching
yourself very carefully you just keep
adding to that 25
000 until you've until you want to pull
that money out
and build your down payment and make you
make your purchase in other words yep
and james i like that you're not rushing
to hurry up and buy you already said you
don't know where florida is going to be
where you're going to stay
and so uh if you're thinking of another
state i'd advise you get in there
you once you get relocated rent there
for six months to a year
learn about the layout learn about where
you want to live in whatever state it is
and then when you find a place or you
think hey i'm going to be here for three
to five years
then you can think about buying yeah and
you know if you think you're going to be
in tampa for
two to three years even though it's not
quote forever you probably
want to talk about buying because
tampa's a great market it's going to do
extremely well on real estate and it's
going to be a great place for you to be
an owner
but if you think you're going to be gone
within 18 to 24 months you probably
don't want to buy because the expenses
will take out any profits that you would
have made
on the house during that time you gotta
own a house usually in most markets
three to five years to make money on it
usually otherwise you'd lose money with
your expenses on each end
parents out there hear this james's
parents taught him about money and guess
what the boy listened
he not only listened he did it so i want
to encourage you out there
have those conversations with your young
people uh don't have just one that's
called an introduction
but have a series of conversations with
them and help them to understand this so
they can get out and start to apply
it you know i've got a buddy of mine
that was a congressman
um on the wrong side of the island we're
buddies anyway
and he um his daddy was a governor
so he grew up in the governor's mansion
uh and you know what they talked about
at dinner what's that
what do you think politics yeah and
guess what
he's a congressman yep you know what
rich people talk about at dinner
money you know what the rich get richer
or get poor it's not that you're
obsessed with it it's not that you're
greedy it's not that it's
preoccupied but it's part of the rhythm
of your life
a lot of poor people and a lot of broke
people that act like they're rich but
are poor
don't talk about money because every
time they bring it up it puts their
stomach in their throat
in james's house they talked about money
oh and they did something about it they
paid for his college
and uh so he's completely set up not
only by the
financial contribution towards college
but by the fact that he
obviously learned yeah his mom and dad
the rhythm of their life was they
discussed
you know what you discuss at your dinner
tables what your kids are going to
become
do you want them to be spiritual giants
then you discuss god
wow you talk about scripture at the
dinner table do you want them to
uh be good with money you talk about
money and you keep it in its proper
perspective you keep it in its place
it's not a god we don't worship it
that's right
but uh those that don't talk about don't
know squat about it to your point yeah
and here's the thing did you hear the
thing out of his mouth he said i was
fortunate enough for my parents to take
care of college
so he had a spirit of gratitude not
entitlement not entitlement
and i'm going to tell you that
entitlement boy oh boy that's another
epidemic we got going on out in our
country today pandemic
it really is it really and truly is i
deserve crap
because i breathe or it's somebody's
fault that you don't have it
no don't do that don't do that just it's
time to wake up and take
the bull by the horns and we got to do
things for ourselves well you know you
become who you hang around with and
i think it's your fault that i don't
have hair
there we go here it goes shot fired here
it goes game on i was trying to be
lovable
yeah it's on man huggable it's fine
we're fighting it's monday and he's
huggable that's right
that's him you do become who you hang
around with well
rachel cruz don't want to come here and
do the show with either one of us
because she knows baldism is coming you
hang out
it's coming never been a
president-elected president of the
united states since television that was
bald
baldism i'm telling you gerald ford
that's a thing no he wasn't elected
that's true
hey he was disappointed he was important
all right and he did not get re-elected
by the way when he ran he got beat
you and i are running in 24. that's it
ramsay and hogan
baldism we're making it happen we're
victims
we are victims of baldism